>>> NOW TO AN UPDA ON RUSSIA'S
INVASION.
NIGHT KREMLIN OFFICIALS ARE
RAISING THE SPECTER OF UKRAINE
DEPLOYING A RADIOACTIVE DIRTY
BOMB.
THE UKRAINIANS DENY THAT
ACCUSATION AS THEIR FORCES RACE
TO RECLAIM TERRITORY BEFORE
WINTER SETS IN.
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT, FRED PLEITGEN,
HAS OUR REPORT FROM THE WAR
ZONE.
>> Reporter: AS UKRAINIAN FORCES
CONTINUE TO MAKE GAINS IN THE
SOUTH OF THE COUNTRY, MOSCOW
ACCELERATING THE EVACUATION OF
PEOPLE FROM THE AREA AROUND
KHERSON.
FAIRIES BRINGING TENS OF
THOUSANDS ACROSS THE DNIPRO
RIVER, THE RUSSIANS SAY TO SAFE,
THE UKRAINE SAYS THESE ARE
ESSENTIALLY DEPORTATIONS.
>> Translator: MY MOTHER NEEDS
MEDICAL TREATMENT, SHE IS ILL.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE AFRAID FOR
OUR LIVES.
WE LIVE NOT FAR FROM THE BRIDGE.
I THINK EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE.
KHERSON WILL HOLD OUT.
>> Reporter: LOCAL OFFICIALS
BELIEVE THIS COULD BE THE
BEGINNING OF A FULL RUSSIAN
RETREAT FROM THIS AREA.
>> Translator: THE OCCUPIERS AND
COLLABORATORS ARE LEAVING THE
WEST PART OF THE REGION IN A
DRAMATIC WAY.
THIS HAPPENS ALONG WITH THE
TOTAL LOOTING OF KHERSON CITY
AND THE REGION WEST OF THE
RIVER.
BUT UKRAINE'S MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE SAY THEY BELIEVE
RUSSIA IS ACTUALLY BUILDING UP
ITS FORCES HERE FOR A MASSIVE
STAND RATHER THAN READYING FOR A
WITHDRAWAL.
BUT AS VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TROOPS
LOSE GROUND, OFFICIALS IN MOSCOW
ARE MAKING TROUBLING
ACCUSATIONS.
IN A CALL WITH SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE LLOYD AUSTIN, RUSSIA'S
DEFENSE MINISTER, SHOIGU
ALLEGING THAT UKRAINE IS
PLANNING TO DETONATE A SO-CALLED
DIRTY BOMB.
A RUSSIAN GENERAL ADDING TO THE
CLAIMS.
>> Translator: THE PROVOCATION
IS AIMED AT ACCUSING RUSSIA OF
USING WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION AT THE UKRAINIAN
THEATRE OF OPERATIONS THAT WOULD
LAUNCH A POWERFUL ANTI-RUSSIAN
CAMPAIGN, IN ORDER TO UNDERMINE
THE CONFIDENCE IN MOSCOW.
>> Reporter: KYIV SHARPLY
REJECTS THE ALLEGATIONS, EVEN
ASKING THE INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC
ENERGY AGENCY TO INSPECT ITS
CIVILIAN NUCLEAR SITES.
THE IAEA ALREADY HAS STAFF IN
THE ZAPORIZHZHIA NUCLEAR PLANT
TRYING TO PREVENT AN ATOMIC
DISASTER THERE.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT HURLING THE
ALLEGATIONS BACK AT MOSCOW.
>> Translator: NEVER AGAIN WILL
RUSSIA BE ABLE TO DICTATE
ANYTHING TO ANYONE.
IT NO LONGER HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO DICTATE.
THE WORLD SEES THAT.
RUSSIAN POTENTIAL IS BEING
WASTED NOW ON A WAR AGAINST OUR
STATE AND THE ENTIRE FREE WORLD.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS
CONTINUED TO HIT UKRAINE WITH
LONG-DISTANCE MISSILES AND
DRONES THIS WEEKEND IN MYKOLAIV
AND ELSE WHERE.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS ARE
HITTING CIVILIAN AREAS LIKE
RIGHT HERE, KILLING AND WOUNDING
SCORES OF PEOPLE.
BUT THE AIR CAMPAIGN IS ALSO
TAKING A MASSIVE TOLL ON THE
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY, LEAVING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WITHOUT POWER.
THE UKRAINIANS SAY RUSSIA'S AIR
STRIKES WON'T STOP THEIR
ADVANCE.
KYIV'S ARMY LOOKING TO RETAKE AS
MUCH OF THEIR TERRITORY AS
POSSIBLE BEFORE WINTER SETS IN.
AND, WOLF, RUSSIA'S AIR CAMPAIGN
POSSIBLY ALSO CONTINUING
TONIGHT.
WE HAD AIR RAID SIRENS A COUPLE
OF MINUTES AGO THAT WERE VERY
LOUD IN THE CENTER OF DNIPRO.
MEANWHILE, THE NATO SECRETARY
GENERAL ALSO COMING OUT AND
REJECTING THOSE ALLEGATIONS MADE
BY RUSSIA ABOUT THAT DIRTY BOMB,
CERTAINLY IN LINE WITH WHAT THE
U.S. IS SAYING AND SOME OF THE
U.S.'S KEY ALLIES.
>> STAY SAFE OVER THERE.
FRED PLEITGEN REPORTING, THANK
YOU.
>>> WE HAVE RETIRED GENERAL
WESLEY CLARK AND CONTRIBUTOR ON
RUSSIAN AFFAIRS, JOE DAUGHTERTY.
FIRST ON THE ACCUSATION THAT
UKRAINE IS GOING TO USE A DIRTY
BOMB CONTAINING RADIOACTIVE
MATERIAL.
IS THAT IN FACT A WARNING THAT
RUSSIA COULD TAKE THAT DANGEROUS
STEP?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS AND
AN EFFORT TO DISTRACT AND BRING
CRITICISM AND TO JUST PUT CHAOS
INTO THE PUBLIC DIALOGUE ABOUT
UKRAINE.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE REASONS
WHY RUSSIA WOULD SAY THIS, BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY A WAY OF COVERING
THEIR OWN PREPARATIONS, POSSIBLY
TO USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON,
POSSIBLY IN THE KHERSON AREA,
POSSIBLY BY SAYING THAT THEY
STRUCK FIRST TO PREVENT UKRAINE
FROM DOING THIS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS IT'S NOT
TRUE.
IT IS PROPAGANDA.
IT'S INFORMATION WAR.
>> YEAH, JUST HOW DANGEROUS,
JILL, IS THIS BRINKSMANSHIP
THAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THINK IT'S VERY DANGEROUS,
WOLF.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH KIND OF THE
LITANY OF WHAT COULD HAPPEN WITH
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
PRESIDENT PUTIN BASICALLY SAYING
I HAVE ALL THE WEAPONS AT MY
DISPOSAL AND I WILL USE THEM TO
DEFEND RUSSIA.
OF COURSE THAT MEANS STRATEGIC,
AS WELL AS TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, AND NOW WE'RE DOWN INTO
THE DIRTY BOMB AREA.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY'VE KIND OF
COVERED THE WATERFRONT ON THIS.
BUT I THINK WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS
RUSSIA AND EVEN THE SOVIET UNION
BEFORE THAT HAS USED THIS
TECHNIQUE, IT'S REALLY THE FALSE
FLAG TECHNIQUE WHERE YOU ACCUSE
THE OTHER GUY OF DOING WHAT YOU,
YOURSELF, ARE PLANNING TO DO.
NOW, WE DON'T KNOW, AS WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE GENERAL,
EVERYTHING BEHIND THIS.
BUT I THINK CONSTANTLY TALKING
ABOUT NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND A
WEAPON, A DIRTY BOMB CAN REALLY
SOW A LOT OF CHAOS AND REALLY
AFFECT THE CIVILIAN POPULATION.
THAT IS VERY DANGEROUS.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS.
GENERAL CLARK, WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THE DRAMATIC DEVELOPMENTS ON
THE BATTLEFIELD RIGHT NOW IN THE
SOUTHERN KHERSON REGION?
>> SO IT LOOKS LIKE THE RUSSIANS
ARE TRYING TO PULL PEOPLE OUT.
THEY WANT THOSE PEOPLE, THEY
WANT TO TAKE THE CHILDREN, THEY
WANT TO REPOPULATE PARTS OF
RUSSIA, PERHAPS.
THEY WANT TO TAKE THEM AWAY FROM
UKRAINE BECAUSE PART OF THIS IS
A POPULATION WAR.
THEY ALSO SAID THEY WANT TO
CREATE A FORTRESS IN KHERSON.
FINE, THEY'RE GOING TO BRING A
FEW MORE TROOPS IN, TRY TO FIGHT
FOR THE CITY, MAYBE.
MAYBE WHAT THEY WANT TO DO IS
SUCK THE UKRAINIAN FORCES IN
THERE IN A PREMATURE OFFENSIVE,
PUT THEM IN A VULNERABLE
POSITION AND THEN CONCENTRATE
FIRE POWER OR MAYBE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AGAINST THEM.
BUT CLEARLY IT'S SHAPING UP TO
BE A MAJOR CONFRONTATION OF
FORCES THAT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
CHANGE THE NATURE OF THE VERY
CAUTIOUS, VERY CAREFUL
INTELLIGEN